I want to jump to this Twitter thread
from Jeff Morris Jr at jmj he's managing
partner at chapter 1 and he writes at
the new internet former VP of product at
Tinder VP of product and revenue he says
the ticktock war why high school and
college kids are getting the wrong
information about Hamas and Israel he
said I spent the weekend trying to
reverse engineer the Tik Tok algorithm
as I am convinced this is the reason we
are losing the information war with high
school and college students one red flag
was seeing San Francisco high school
students who were aggressively
anti-israel and asking myself where they
were getting their news their protests
happened right after the fake New York
Times headline that accused Israel of
the hospital bomb I also want to pause
real quick uh as well the Wall Street
Journal maintains that the video we see
of the rocket exploding in mid air and
payload falling was what hit the par
parking lot the New York Times got the
story wrong apologized and then came out
with another story like actually that
video you watch was wrong our analysis
says that's actually now hit the
hospital and it's like very convenient
for the New York Times who flubbed this
one really really bad to be like
actually we weren't that wrong so I
think the New York Times is full of it I
think the New York Times is a captured
organization that is desperately trying
to be Pro Hamas we saw this with the Tom
Cotton uh uh oped the oped editor got
fired because Tom Cotton wrote an oped
about bringing the sending the military
because of the BLM riots
New York Times we know for a long time
look what Barry Weiss had to say it is a
captured leftist institution yeah let's
read he says the bigger red flag was
seeing 51% of Americans aged 18 to 24
believe Hamas terrorists who raped and
murdered innocent women and children
believe Hamas was
justified my high school classmates who
lived through 911 would never believe
this that's right look at this you guys
seen this this this uh chart he's uh uh
this this graph is actually missing one
other important component not only do 18
to 24 year olds in the majority believe
it was justified but in the majority
believe it was
genocide I believe it's 60 was it
63% of uh 18 to 24 year olds believe
what Hamas did was genocide and 51%
believe it is Justified mhm that is
insane W let's read more he says why do
high school students in San Francisco
hate Israel so much i' assume very few
of them have been to Israel let alone
have a fully formed view of a
multigenerational conflict they're 16
years old and living California let's be
serious for a minute really for Gen Z
Tik Tok is the new search engine it's
the number one search engine for more
than half of gen Z it's the primary news
source for many younger demos and while
we have justifiable concerns about the
New York Times and mainstream media this
has become a Tik Tock War when I
discovered through data and user testing
what I have discovered is extremely
concerning and I believe requires more
attention as this is an actual national
security issue when I engaged with one
post on Tik Tok supporting opposing
views my entire feed became aggressively
anti-israel it was as as if I was placed
in an AB test variant and was told to
see this war with Israel being the evil
side as I looked at the tactics and data
I saw that much of Tik Tok is being
controlled by anti-israel bot Farms paid
commentators commenters likers sharers
much of which is paid for by Hamas
supporting organizations I then looked
at the data and saw that Israel is
losing the Tik toac War by a long shot
as an example the top three three
billion top hashtag is three billion
views for Palestine versus 200 million
for Israel if you look at the other
hashtags it is clear that isra Israel
has a distribution issue so he goes on a
bit but you get the point he says he's
still researching I actually think the
point is this China is trying to get the
us into multiple Wars at once and the
purpose of this is get the us into war
in Ukraine in the Mediterranean and
itself this is going to create a massive
conflict in the US it's it's it look
what we're seeing with Cooper Union
yesterday Ron Coleman made a really
important point a video of Jewish
student students locked in the library
as far leftists are banging on the door
screaming Free Palestine and the latest
reporting that came out is that the LI I
believe it was the librarian told these
students to hide in the attic I kid you
not wow now I'm wondering what attic is
in the building and if they're just
saying that because it's like invoking
some serious uh images but how does
something like that happen where these
these are just some Jewish students in
New York and Ron Coleman says they're
not Israeli students right that's right
the the the the leftists did not go to
the room where Israelis were they went
to the room where the Jewish students
were banging on the door and screaming
Free Palestine they don't see a
distinction so I actually think this is
hey it's Tik Tock it's China and we get
these doofy Republicans who are like
they're spying on us no dude they're
manipulating young people hey we're
banned on Tik Tok I wonder why that is
me too you're on Tik Tok a lot you said
before the show is this what you're
seeing too
I'm I am on Tik Tok oh sorry did I just
expose you no no no no no no I am on Tik
Tock I got um banned a couple times
Carly B Bonet who helps push her push
war himself she's been banned like 25 25
times we just started a war room one and
it's yeah they ban war room all the time
anything that is you know against any of
that so so and you don't and when you're
you don't really scroll through it
yourself you just use it for war room I
have my own personal one too yeah are
you seeing it in your algorithm I'm
wondering I'm asking I'm asking because
if it's complete takeover or if it's
targeted young people yeah it is it's a
takeover and I see even in the live
streams they have like you know the the
the live
whatevers it's all pro Palestine like
just like it all of it I've wondered and
I can't remember who made this point in
the past week that I've been on IRL that
um one one of the things that happened
post 911 was that to avoid uh
encouraging an anti-islam anti-muslim
sentiment uh textbook companies
partnered with organizations that are
pro-islam and there's an influence there
believe I believe it almost and it could
be part of the algorithm but like if I
watch one you know video about like you
know oh this is what's really happening
and it's that I'll just see all those it
makes me wonder if if students
particularly vulnerable because of this
uh precaution that was potentially taken
when they were publishing textbooks post
911 in addition to the fact that it's
being pushed on them social media so
there's no narrative right if you I mean
I felt like this I went I grew up in a
liberal bluish blue area and I always
leaned conservative and I remember there
were times in school where you're being
taught something but you know you're
reading something different at home the
conversations are different among your
family you can kind of you know to
question it whereas if it's hitting you
from social media which is basically how
you run your entire after school life
maybe in school too and your teachers
are presenting information that says you
know actually this is how this conflict
started and you know this side gets this
wrong and whatever if there is no Escape
if there's no no way for them to see on
the outside unless they have family in
Israel unless they have a connection
somewhere else I have only seen Pro
promus type videos on Tik Tok yeah I'm
not surprised with the college stuff cuz
I think they were all primed for this
after the like Riot summer with BL and
this is just like an extension of that
so they see violence as righteous and
they were young I mean if you're a high
school student now in 2020 if you're if
you're if you're 17 now you were 13
that's like what the end of middle
school and so you grew up in a time
where uh social media and really
outlandish protests that Verge in the
point of Destruction and violence are
the norm and perhaps even celebrated
that it was cool that all of your
friends older siblings were getting
likes for attending these things and
throwing bricks through windows or
whatever else it's the cultural
revolution it's the red guard yeah and
they've been waiting they've been
waiting to have their chance have
something to want violence right even
though it's the same crowd that says
silence is violence or words are
violence these are Will Chamberlain
pointed out these are people who cheered
not not every single one but in New York
City cheered for Hamas and are now
because of what's going on in Maine
arguing to disarm people yeah yeah
unbelievable it seems wild they hate
their political enemies and they'll do
they have no moral Center and they'll
say whatever they have to do to destroy
their politic enemies how about how
about uh
Hamas breaks through the the barriers
paraglides in murders a bunch of
civilians and and men women and children
and then Israel strikes
Gaza when Hamas storms in what do we see
we see people in New York City cheering
for the killing of civilians then when
Israel bombs Palestine we see these
people saying they bomb Gaza they say oh
no they're killing civilians and they're
crying and saying how could you support
this and I'm just like bro you were
supporting it yeah it's okay when it
someone else's civilians Gaza Israel
people okay like I I I'm not I'm not
Israel or paltin or whatever all I know
is people are dying but y'all were
celebrating civilians dying and now
you're complaining about civilians dying
I don't think you actually care about
civilians dying right no I don't think
so either I think there's also a level
of you know one of the things that I
have heard told over and over again is
that uh one of the reasons people say
you should support Palestine support
Hamas or whatever is because they're
being colonized right they they the
colonize are oppressing them and this is
actually very similar to the language
that we hear with BLM and with other
critical race Theory right exactly and
so if if all of our young people are
trained sort of Allah Pavlo and his dog
that when they hear a certain word they
know exactly how they're supposed to
respond they know how to fall in mind
right if you hear colonizer you know
which side you're supposed to be on
because in our history which is the only
lens they're allowed to they can view it
through and part of that I would say is
probably immaturity right it's it's they
haven't experienced the world they don't
know anything but also you know they are
only ever allowed to hear certain terms
and line up on certain sides it's all
indoctrination I mean you know you go
back to Japanese Korean culture like way
back when I mean you know Japanese
colonized Korea you know I mean there's
colonizers everywhere so would the
modern day teenager be on Korea
side that's a good question um I didn't
I haven't thought about that that's the
word they hear that's how they know how
to line up I think part of it is that
there's not a lot of critical analysis
they just want to have the viral moment
and again I I've said this before but
you know that story about the student
who wrote uh black lives matters you
know however many times on his college
application and got admitted to whatever
ivy league like these kids are going to
present their Tik toks being like I got
every one of my school to dance in the
Pro Palestine Pro Hamas rally and so I'm
very very important and you should let
me into your school like this is what
they think will build their potential
activist future on which is linked to
both their social value and their
intellectual value you know
these the the views of these students
will never change I mean in small
numbers for sure people do change but
what people need to understand about
Generations is that when we see
according to PE research gen Z being
slightly more conservative than
Millennials in some areas they assume
this means that jenz is learning these
things when in reality it's just
conservatives have more kids more kids
are being raised these these young
people who are chanting from the river
to the Sea
it's locked in they've chanted it
they've said it it's part of who they
are and it will be painful to admit they
were wrong only some people ever have
the strength to actually go through
these Transformations and be like what
was I thinking yeah most of them when
they're in their 30s are going to be
part of extremist groups in some fashion
or
another this is why you know I when I we
were talking last time about Marxism and
in the college world and then you know
I'm thinking of like domestic terrorists
such as Weather Underground literally
blowing people up you know and they're a
vow marxists they they're very open
about it they eventually go to jail
people like Bill aers or Susan Rosenberg
they Susan Rosenberg gets pardoned by
Bill Clinton on his last day in office
she becomes a professor she's espousing
all those things they all are you know
they eventually uh even my beloved Cuomo
uh mass murderer in New York let out on
his last day in office uh a Weather
Underground person who built a bomb and
killed people they take over the
colleges there's a lot of them they
breed this world where they they talk
about how Marxism has will be the
paradise people but anyway Susan
Rosenberg what does she do other than
being professor she starts thousand
currents and then act blue what does ACT
blue do they help siphon the money for
black lives matter which in my opinion
is another domestic terrorist
organization so it's like I just see a
straight line through all this where
that's that's the kind of violence that
that those campuses breede I think
Veritas had a report I want to be very
careful with my language here alleging
that China was funneling money to
political parties through act blue I'm
not entirely sure what the report I
wouldn't be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised either I think a big story I
don't have surprised through college a
lot of colleges rely especially small
colleges rely on uh foreign donations to
make to make their quotas at the end of
the year I mean you have so many foreign
students from China just you know we
have professors during Co getting
arrested for uh ties to China for
certain things uh I forget it was
Espionage or what they were doing or
there's like some guy with a suitcase
and and viruses in it it was crazy stuff
was going on uh back then you have send
me a link cuz I don't know that yeah
that was that's a deep cut from like
three years ago I mean that was the
thing about Co though there was both so
much happen
s just I remember you're talking about
like there was a there was a a person
that was traveling with
like viruses yeah right and they they
somehow like fell out because they were
carrying them in some way that would
made it like it very sketchy right yeah
yeah remember
that it's O'Keefe Media Group four
months ago FEC story update Chinese
money involved in act blue donations
exactly what it Chinese money's
everywhere and G's the new ma uh and and
Ma's culture Revolution and and Bill A's
and weather ground look up to Ma you
know I I see that as the the poison
that's destroying this country I think
one of the problems we have is children
are being raised by children and now by
algorithms and adults want to be
children thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net